Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie et aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour le cinquième et dernier épisode d'Inside.
C'est parti, souvenez-vous :
On était au milieu de ces gens pendus... oh il a bougé
qui sont encore vivant apparemment, ces gens pendus par la tête
j'allais dire.
On sait pas pourquoi ils sont là,
et pourquoi ils sont pas avec les autres zombies de l'autre côté.
On sait pas non plus pourquoi en dessous là, souvenez-vous, il y a de l'air
et que l'eau est au dessus de l'air... c'est très bizarre
Ah, il y a
une porte. Ah, ça part sur un vaisseau spatial !
Mais non... voilà... oooh
Mec. Bah, du coup, je peux rentrer dedans là, apparemment.
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?!
C'est quoi ce délire de vaisseau extraterrestre là ?
Je ne comprends pas.
Est-ce qu'on va enfin
tomber sur des gens qui sont comme nous.
qui essaient de s'échapper ? Et on va former la résistance avec eux.
C'est ça la question.
On aimerait bien... mais bizarrement on n'a pas trop l'impression que ça va arriver.
Oulah... ok.
Alors. Bon, on continue.
Alors, regardez, là-haut ils tournent un truc.
Y'a une caméra.
C'est quoi ce délire mec ?
Attends là je suis sous l'eau encore ? Non.
C'est hyper stressant d'avoir l'eau au-dessus de nous. J'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre le délire.
Quoi ?! Attend !
On choisit le level de l'eau sur demande.
C'est fantastique.
Ah ok, le problème c'est que
la porte s'ouvre que quand il y a de l'eau au-dessus.
Ah, je suppose que j'atteins pas l'eau d'ici.
Si ?
Est-ce que je peux atteindre l'eau de là ?
Oh.
L'au-delà.
Vous voyez si j'arrivais à atteindre l'eau là,
on pourrait aller en face.
Heuuuu...
Comment on peut faire ?
Est-ce qu'on va tomber, du coup, sur un truc qui peut nous aider là-bas ?
Une caisse, peut-être ?
Ouais.
Ça va nous aider, ça.
Voilà, on en avait bien besoin.
Ooooh !
Ah non, ils vont chercher les...
Faut que je me cache ?
Je pense qu'il faut que je me cache.
Que faites-vous ?
Et c'est quoi ? Y'a un mec avec son fils. P*tain, mais c'est méga glauque, mon gars.
Il a 8 ans, il est pas choqué de ce qui se passe ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire avec ces gens ?
Ils vont pas les pendre par la tête dans l'eau, quand même. Hein ?
Attend mais, en fait, je peux avancer.
Ils me verront pas voilà. Ah ah !
Ils verront juste une caisse bouger toute seule.
Ok. Bon bah, ils ont juste pris les gens dans la cellule.
Je sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire.
Alors. À partir de là...
Ok.
Va falloir mettre l'eau pour pouvoir mettre la caisse sur le bon rebord.
Voilà.
Non, elle va où, elle va où, elle va où, elle va où ?
Arrête !
Ah bah non, c'est bon !
Non. En fait, c'est pas grave si elle va en haut, on va juste la mettre au-dessus de cette plateforme-là.
Voilà. Et en fait, ça va nous permettre d'atteindre l'eau.
Attend, c'est hyper bizarre ce délire. Là, on dirait qu'ils font une émission de télé les mecs.
Arrêtez d'être glauque à un moment s'il vous plaît.
Ok, la caisse retombe, voilà
Et ensuite ça.
Ok, là on devrait être bon.
C'est parti.
Hop là, parfait. Vous avez vu ? Il y a pas de son dans cette pièce.
C'est, c'est effrayant mec.
Il y a zéro p*tain de son !
C'est chaud non ?
Que dans cette pièce !
Si je vais là, il y a du son ?
Voyez ?
Et là-bas, y'en avait pas. Enfin, bref.
Alors, on continue.
Faut aller en bas, vous pensez ?
De toute façon, on peut respirer sous l'eau maintenant, on a ...
C'est quoi ce délire, le mec en bas là ?
Ils font quoi en bas là ?
Oh d'accord ! Ok ! P*tain, j'avais oublié que sous l'eau, y'a pas d'eau.
C'est l'inverse !
Ok. Bon bah, on continue tout droit hein ? Écoutez.
Alors. Donc là, pareil. Faudrait qu'on ait de l'eau pour pouvoir atteindre le bouton, je suppose ?
Comment on fait ?
Comment on peut faire ça ?
Ah regardez, voilà. C'est pareil. Ça va permettre de contrôler le ... l'eau.
Ok.
Attends, non l'eau est ...
Oh !
Ooooooooh !
Ooooh !
Mais, attends mec on dirait ... On dirait même plus des ...
Wow.
Ah ! Du coup, j'suis leurs sauveur, c'est ça ?
Ooooh !
Mais on dirait même plus des humains ! On dirait de la pâte à modeler mon gars.
C'est terrible. Bah, du coup, on va pouvoir atteindre le bouton.
On va faire une p*tain de pyramide.
Ça va passer nickel. Mais, ils sont morts en fait. Regardez, il y en a une qui tient sa tête quand même ...
ou qui a la tête au bout du bras ou ...
Bon, en tout cas, vous allez m'aider et on va s'échapper tous ensemble
et je vous ferai un bon gâteau au chocolat à la fin de tout ça.
Hein ? On est trop loin encore ?
Je peux pas l'atteindre, je peux pas l'atteindre. J'ai essayé maintes et maintes fois, ça marche pas.
Comment faire ?
Pourquoi ? Regardez ! Pourquoi, lui par terre, il se lève pas ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il a ? Il est mort ?
Il a même plus de corps p*tain !
C'est quoi ça ?
Aaaah, va falloir rebaisser le levier tout simplement, ok ... Ok, j'ai compris !
J'ai compris !
Ok !
Merci les amis !
Je vous aimes ! P*tain, vous déchirez !
Voilà !
À mon avis, c'est là où l'eau est basse.
Je vais pouvoir l'atteindre, ouais c'est ça, ok !
Yaaaah
Niquel. Parfait.
Est-ce qu'ils nous suivent toujours ? Ouaiis.. Il me suivent
En fait, je pense qu'ils me suivent parce que ...
Vous savez quand j'ai eu la capacité de respirer sous l'eau.
Je pense qu'il m'ont implanter le truc qui fait que ... Enfin ...
Une sorte de... Ils m'ont implanté le casque en fait ... En moi.
C'est pour ça qu'ils me suivent à mon avis.
Je vois pas pourquoi The Grudge m'a aidé, hein ?
Moi je l'aimais pas du tout, hein ? Allez on y va. Allez.
Question de timing
Oui ! Au passage on l'a eu.
Oh ! J'ai tué des potos m*rde.
Aller venez vite avant que la porte se referme.
Venez les amis, on va créer une armée, on va se rebeller !
Ah ok.
J'ai cru qu'ils étaient contre nous. P*tain, j'ai eu extrêmement peur.
Donc du coup, je contrôle toutes les personnes devant lesquelles je passe, quoi.
J'ai... le pouvoir en moi ?
Je suis l'élu.
The choose on one.
[Traduction : Le choix d’un]
Mais qui qu... dissèque des gens quoi.
C'est incroyable ! Ah vous allez devoir m'envoyer de l'autre côté
sinon je vais mourir, les amis.
Faites moi rêver !
Ouuiiii !
Eweuuuh
Niquel ! Je vais vous ouvrir les gars.
Nooon !
Je vous aimais p*tain, je vous aimais tellement !
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave on va trouver un moyen.
On va retrouver un moyen.
Il y en a un qui part en courant là-bas ...
Deux mecs qui partent en courant là-bas !
Ok... Très bizarre !
Ah mais je peux sauter maintenant que je suis en bas, ils vont m'amortir, suis-je bête les amis ...
Suis-je bête ?
Amortissez moi !
Meeerciii p*tain ! Vous êtes adorable !
Mais j'aimerai trop les emmener tous avec moi. Il y en a pas un ou deux qui veulent venir ?
P*tain.
Ils nous auraient bien aidés quoi... Ils sont très gentil,
ils amortissent les chutes,
ils m'envoient en l'air.. Il s'envoient en l'air aussi...
Ah, c'est un ascenseur, c'est bon !
On va les récupérer pas de panique. Aller venez les gars.
Ah m*rde !
Je les ai juste fais monter p*tain.
Alors. Ok.
Du coup, ils me suivent par au-dessus, c'est ça ?
Ouais ils sont au dessus de moi... Mais non !
Putain les gars, on est trop c*n !
On est très très c*n !
En fait non, c'est ce qu'il fallait faire comme ça ils prennent ascenseur avec moi et on arrive tous en bas.
Tous ensemble. C'est tout beau tout rose?
Voilà ! Niquel !
Oh pardon ! P*tain.
Ça me fait trop mal au cœur ! Ils ont l'air tellement faibles !
J'aime pas du tout les taper !
Allez, on y va ! Ok...
Je suis avec les gars sûrs !
Rien ne peut nous arriver.
On va soulever cette porte tous ensemble. Allez y.
Allez y les gars !
Ok !
Oh p*tain, attention la chute, les gars !
C'est terrible.
Alors lui...
Voyez celui qui est tout devant là ? Qui tient sa tête ? Il me fait vraiment bader.
Il y a des gens au fond qui courent et qui ont l'air normaux.
Est-ce que c'est un bâtiment qui héberge ceux qui ont réussis à s'enfuir ?
Non, là on rêve.
C'est sûr on rêve ! Merci pour tout les mecs.
On se revoit très vite c'est promis ! Je vais vous libérer... de... ce mal qui vous ronge.
Donc, on arrive dans ce bâtiment.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ici ?
Là, on arrive vraiment dans les bâtiments, j'ai l'impression, principaux.
Vous voyez ? À base de cigare,
de PC, de table où ils dissèquent les gars.
C'est très bizarre !
Aller triste et c'est bon ça.
Hop !
Regardez les téléphones ! On dirai...
On dirait qu'ils sont tous partis en courant d'un coup s'ils avaient eu peur de quelque chose.
Mais de qu.. De quoi ont...
ont-ils eu peur ? C'est ça la question.
Regardez ! Ils s'enfuient tous, hein ?
Je rêve pas, hein ! Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils savent qu'il y a un...
... un élu ? Que je peux contrôler tout le monde ?
Non ? P*tain ça se trouve j'ai des théories tellement pétées.
Regardez...
Oh... C'est glauque.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils leur font à ces gens ? Et ils filment !
Et il y a des gens devant des chaises qui regardent ça !
C'est quoi ce délire mon pote ?
Regardez, il court à côté de nous lui, il a aucunes gênes ! Il se prend des chaise en plus !
Monsieur vous ne pouvez pas nous en dire plus ? Sur ce qu'il se passe ?
Il faudrait que j'atteigne ce... cette échelle.
Ah ok, ils ont tous couru pour assister à quelque chose en fait.
Assister à quoi ? Qu'est ce qu'il se passe ?
Eh je veux voir !
Il y a quoi ? S'il vous plait !
Bon, on peux pas voir.
Ok on va prendre ça et on va pouvoir atteindre l'échelle.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils regardent tous là ? J'suis curieux !
Vous savez c'est l'effet de foule, il y a du monde à un endroit et toi aussi t'as envie de voir ce qu'il y a,
alors que si ça se trouve, il n'y a rien.
Là y a un...
Pan.. Panneau de commande...
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec ça ? On peut sauter au dessus ?
Oui !
Non !
Ah ok, j'ai compris, j'ai compris... Pardon ! Il faut juste faire ça !
Voilà !
Nickel !
Ensuite, on va s'accrocher au poteau qui est là... Hop !
Ok, on y est !
Attend, on touche au but là !
Qu'est-ce qu'on va...
Ah, on va pouvoir voir ce qu'il y a de l'autre côté ?
Oh j'aimerai trop !
Ok... C'est parti.
On descend !
Tout le monde regarde... Qu'est-ce qu'il y a là-bas au milieu ?
Putain, on va encore pas voir, c'est chiant !
On veut voir !
Bah lui, le petit garçon en fait, il n'a pas envie de voir... Juste il s'enfuit... Bon remarque, il a raison
Il a totalement raison.
C'est lui qui sera dans la cuve sinon, c'est lui que les gens regarderont.
Si ça se trouve on va atterrir là où les gens regardent.. Justement.
Non ?
Non.
Oula... Faut... Faut pas avoir peur là ! Ok...
D'accord...
Ah, je sais pas où faut aller hein je le tente... Ah, y a une échelle là.
Mais on est en train de s'enfoncer de ouf !
Où on va comme ça mec ?
Ho ! Mais je crois que, depuis le début du jeu, si tu regardes à quel point on s'est enfoncé, on doit être à 1 km sous terre mon gars !
Oula...
C'est quoi ça mec ?
Attendez on va aller voir tout de suite... De toute façon on peut respirer sous l'eau, on a peur de quoi ?
Eeeeh... Eh !
Ok.. Et ça...? Heiiiin... heiin !
Ok.
Là... Aaah ! Regardez là ! Ok nickel !
Du coup, on va pouvoir atteindre la barre ici... Je sais pas trop à quoi elle va servir...
Ok.
Ah ça ouvre le... le truc du dessus. Donc on va pouvoir aller dans le truc du dessus et voir ce qu'il y a.
Mais non... C'est génial mec !
Ah merde... Ouais mais le problème c'est que j'ai pas le temps d'atteindre le truc... ça se referme... Comment faire ?
Comment faire ?
Est-ce que il faut pas le lancer... Et le temps que ça se lance, ce sera bon ?
Ouais c'est ça ! Aller go go go go go, dépêche toi, dépêche toi, dépêche toi, dépêche toi, dépêche toiiii !
Heeeen, c'est bon !
On est bon et du coup ça va direct nous envoyer dans le trou. C'est parti !!!
Wow !
Voilà, c'était sûr !
C'était sûr mec. C'est nous qui nous retrouvons devant les gens. P*tain c'est horrible. À poil...
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est quoi ça mec ?
Une boule de...  de chaire humaine ?
Avec des jambes...
et des bras ?
C'est des gens qui ont fusionnés ?
Alors attend on peut retirer les capteurs ? Ouais.
C'est quoi ça mec ?
What ???
J'arrive pas à comprendre ce que c'est...
P*tain, en plus le truc m'agrippe au passage c'est ignoble !
Ah... Ah !
Je me suis fait avoir, je suis dedans !
Mais mec... Je contrôle la boule !
Mais mec ... Je perd la boule aussi !
Mais mec ...
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on est devenu ?
Est-ce qu'on peut pas heu ...
péter genre la vitre
derrière laquelle il y a tout le monde là ?
Ah, c'est glauque !
Si ! Regardez, on est en train de la péter.
On est en train de l'arracher.
Allez.
Oh !
Et on peut bouger ?
Mais mon gars ...
Mais ça part en couille de ouf !
On s'enfuit.
Bah attend, on est hyper puissant, tu me diras.
Ah !
Ah, c'est terrifiant !
Ho !
C'est terrifiant, mec !
Non non non, mon con !
Ça marchera pas !
J'arrache ça !
On est 28 dans ce corps.
Tu peux rien faire.
Ah ah ! Il a bien peur le mec !
J'espère qu'on va bien l'écraser !
Wouah !
La vengeance des gens lobotomisé !
On est de retour, bitch !
On est ... Oh oui, mes potos !
Comment vous allez ?
Joignez vous à la boule !
Vous voulez pas vous rejoindre à la boule ?
Vous pensez qu'ils peuvent la porter ?
J'ai trop envie de voir.
Attendez !
Ah ah ah !
C'est génial !
Allez, on continue les gars !
Ah les gars ! J'aurais besoin de vous !
Ils nous auront été tellement utiles ces gens là.
Mais je pense qu'il sont mieux là où ils sont que dans cette boule de ... humaine, quand même. Non ?
On va pas se mentir.
Merci les gars !
Ho !
C'est répuniant !
C'est répuniant mec !
Ah !
Ho !
Salut !
Vous allez bien ou quoi ?
C'est la boule humaine !
C'est la boule de gras !
C'est le kyste !
On va l'appeler le kyste !
Allez, on y va.
On pète tout sur notre passage.
On veut s'enfuir.
Oh !
Ho !
Putain mec !
Comment on est bourrin !
C'est impressionnant !
Allez, on la tire ! C'est notre caisse ! Ça va nous aider
à grimper là-haut, de l'autre côté !
C'est dégueulasse mais c'est cool à la fois, non ?
Si je m'attendais à ça les gars,
Si je m'attendais à ça les gens, putain.
Ah ! C'est dur de monter sur le truc !
On est tellement gros !
Putain, on est trop gros. Attend.
Il faut vraiment pousser contre le truc.
Ho !
Elle est répuniante !
Elle est tellement répuniante. C'est affreux mec !
Regarde !
C'est affreux !
J'en ait marre !
Yii hiiii !
Allez les gars ! Laissez passez s'il vous plait !
Vous m'avez fait mal pendant 20 ans !
C'est moi qui vous le rend maintenant !
On défonce l'entreprise... Ho ! Le mur, carrément.
Oh, c'est le patron ?
C'est le grand patron ?
Mais non !
Qu'est-ce que t'as oser nous faire, mec ?
Tiens !
Oh, on l'a défoncé !
Oh !
On l'a explosé mec !
Ho... On l'a explosé.
C'était jouissif, p*tain.
Allez, c'est parti !
Faut prendre de la vitesse pour péter le mur là-bas.
Non ?
Ah, faut le soulever ?
Comment on fait pour le casser... Il devrait y avoir un truc...
Voilà, ça.
On peut vraiment se faire un...
Ok, c'est bon.
On va s'aider de ce bout de bois pour péter la porte.
P*tain, elle gène la jambe du mec !
Elle bouge ses jambes par terre...
Ah non, quoi que, c'est peut-être à nous en fait, vas-y.
C'est pas bon, ça ?
C'est pas bon ce que je fais ?
Non, c'est pas bon.
Ok,  je suis débile. Il y avait un bouton juste là !
Je ne l'avais point vu !
Enfin je pense... C'est un bouton.
Bah oui, c'est un bouton.
Dans tout les cas, la porte ne veux pas se péter. Donc, ce n'est pas un bouton.
On est dans le boudin !
Allez vas-y. Lève le.
Lève le.
Oui !
Ah non !
Non ! Ah ah ah !
Je suis dég' !
Ok, on est prêt ?
Heiiiin !
C'était bel et bien un bouton.
Oh non les chiens !
Allez, cassez vous !
Oh ! Je les ai bloqué sous la barre en bois ! Je n'ai pas fait exprès !
Ah non, pas tellement.
Ils aboient juste là ! Ils font pas les malins hein !
Hein, bande de petit FDP ?
Du coup, il faut que je reprenne la barre en bois.
Faut que je me la traine.
Hé, laissez moi en paix, les gars ! On fait pas le poid avec moi !
Non, franchement !
Contre à un petit enfant de 8 ans, y avait du monde, hein !
Allez !
Ok, on y est. C'est bon. On a réussi.
On est dessus. P*tain, c'est très dur de se déplacer quand tu fais 1,5 tonne, c'est vraiment dur.
On s'en sort. Tout le monde nous regarde. Ils sont dég'.
Ouais, ouais.  Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Ouais !
On contrôle la boule, mon gars, que vous avez créé.
Par contre, à chaque fois, on perd un peu de...
de gens. De la masse.
Ce qui est très peu pratique.
Heiin !
Comment tu ouvres ça ? Tu veux pas nous aider, là-bas ?
Le mec derrière son truc ?
Il y a une échelle. Peut-être qu'il faut remonter.
Ah, si. regardez. Ok.
Il ne nous voit pas.
Il va ouvrir la porte, ce c*n.
Et là, on va le choper.
Ah, le s*lop ! On a pas eu le temps !
Ok. C'est histoire du timing.
Il est en train d'ouvrir la porte.
Ok, il a ouvert la porte.
Merci mec, c'est gentil. Il a ouvert pour nous ?
Bon bah, écoute. On y va !
Merci !
C'est sympa, on se souviendra de toi !
Tu fais quoi, toi ?
Mais, je ne veux pas tomber dans ce trou, mec !
Hein ? T'as cru que ça allait marcher pour de vrai ?
En fait, il me guide... Il m'aide... Je...
Non, ils veulent juste que je me barre.
Ecoutez, on va... Ah ah ah !
Ah, c'est hyper satisfaisant de voir un si gros truc passer dans un si petit trou comme ça, hein ?
Il n'y a rien de sexuel.
C'est pas parce que je dis trou qu'il y a un truc sexuel. Vous arrêtez tout de suite.
On a la caisse.
Ça va nous permettre de...
C'est du feu, là-haut. On va éviter quand même.
Attend. Ça doit bien servir à quelque chose.
Ah ! Bah là , juste au-dessus, p*tain !
On va l'envoyer là-haut. Hop !
Clac !
Ok ! Et ça, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est juste une lampe, c'est...
Hop !
Ah, on a pété la lampe !
Et du coup, ça s'ouvre ! Parfait !
On va y aller.
Cette caisse, ça peut nous servir, les amis.
Moi, j'aimerai bien qu'on revoit notre pote The Grudge qui nous a sauvé, quand même.
Et qu'on lui dise...
Merci quoi. Qu'on lui fasse une bise, je sais pas.
C'est un peu grâce à lui qu'on est là.
Oh, il y a du feu ! Non, on va pas se bruler, mec !
Mais non !
Faut pas qu'on brule, mec.
Ah si, il va bruler l'abomination du coup qui a été créé,  vous pensez ?
Non, je pense pas.
Attend, je pense qu'il faut bruler la caisse dedans.
Peut-être, ça va faire quelque chose.
Ah ok ! Elle est en feu !
Il va falloir...
Ah m*rde!
Ok, va falloir l'envoyer au-dessus de ça ? D'accord !
Ok !
Va falloir le ramener dans le trou qu'on a vu tout à l'heure, là où il y avait marqué "Feu" dessus,
sauf qu'il y a une série d'obstacle.
Wow !
Attention à l'eau.
Hop là !
Oui !
Oh, c'est beau !
Oh, mon gars !
C'est génial !
On ramène la flamme olympique, mon pote.
Attend !
C'est dur.
Franchement, c'est pas si simple.
Ah ! Non !
Ah, p*tain !
Si on avait pas 1,5 tonne, on aurait pu se déplacer plus vite.
Oh oui, avec l'élan.
Alors là. Là, c'est passé mais à la perfection, mon gars.
Ok, on y va.
C'est parti !
On va pouvoir l'envoyer dans le truc qui réclame du feu.
Et j'ai aucune idée de ce que ça fait mais,
je pense que ça va être pas mal.
Allez, c'est parti. Qu'est-ce que qui va se passer ?
Wow !
Grosse explosion !
La porte s'ouvre, du coup !
Ouais.
P*tain mon gars, cette boule de gras.
Le kyste humain.
Je m'ne remet pas, mon gars. p*tain.
Mais...
Et du coup, le petit garçon est dans la boule, et il est bien lui, ou...
il a vraiment fusionner avec ? C'est ça que je me demande.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse, là ?
Ah bah, voilà !
On va prendre ça, on va s'en servir... immédiatement.
Et on va pouvoir atteindre le petit truc au-dessus. C'est ça qu'il faut atteindre ?
Je pense.
Ah ! Je vais l'éblouir et ça va le lâcher, c'est ça ?
Ah ah ah ah ah !
Ah ah !
C'est génial !
Ça me fait marrer, voir ce gros truc pendre comme ça.
Allez les mecs, là !
Heiiiiin ! C'est bon !
Oui !
On a tout péter !
Ils sont comme des c*ns, mon gars.
Ah ah ah !
Ça fait moins les malis, hein ?
On se retrouve de l'autre côté du mur, les gars.
Ah, je vais devoir m'aider de ça, quand même.
Yéééééééé !
Le problème, c'est que, vu qu'on est extrêment gros, il faut vraiment pousser les trucs jusqu'au mur.
On ne peux pas sauter.
Hop ! C'est parti !
Je me demande comment ça va se terminer.
Si on va être...
Genre !
Genre, ça va marcher, mec !
Ah bah non ! Faut juste le mettre en dessus ! Ok.
Ok. Faut l'act...
Ok, alors, attend. Je sais.
Tiens. Active le !
Activez le !
Merci les gars !
Ok, on y est !
Oui !
Oui, on est passé !
C'est bon !
Oula... Hé...C'est que des gens tout ça mec, hein ?
Regardez, c'est que des gens.
Ok.
Oh. Il joue avec nous.
Oh, les bâtard !
Bon, on va continuer.
Et là-bas, on a quoi ? On a rien ?
On a rien du tout. Ok.
Comment on fait pour choper ce truc ?
Ok. Du coup, il nous ont piégé, c'est ça ?
On se retrouve dans l'eau...
Et dans le noir, c'est ça ?
D'accord.
Bon, on va bien un petit trou, on ne va pas se mentir.
Ça, regardez. C'est une brèche, non ?
Non.
Si ? Siiii ! Nickel !
On va arracher un deuxième. Voilà.
Ça dégage.
Et on va pouvoir passer !
Ah ! Là, il y a une grille. Regardez.
C'est de ce côté là !
Hop là !
On peux se barrer.
On veux voir la lumière, on ne va pas se mentir.
On veux voir la lumière. On espère un jour
sortir de ce gros corp flasque
et revenir un petit garçon de 8 ans ?
Parce que là, c'est un petit peu chelou comme vie pour un petit garçon de 8 ans.
Ok ! Bon, on continue notre chemin.
Et j'espère qu'on s'en sort, franchement.
Ah, ça va craquer, ça ! Oui, oui, oui !
Beaucoup trop léger.
Ah mais, du coup, on va pouvoir courir
super vite et péter le truc en bois. Regardez.
Attention, gros tas de graisse lancé !
Aaaaah ! Parfait !
Ho ! Mais non ! On s'en est sorti, mec ?
Mais non !
Mais mon gars !
Ah, p*tain. On est en train de raser la forêt.
Ah ah ah !
Mais non !
C'est bon.
On s'en est sorti.
Mais non. On est... On est pas en train de mourir là,  quand même.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
On est mort... c'est ça ?
C'est la fin, ok.
Mais je n'arrive pas à comprendre si on est bien vivant ou pas.
En fait, on bouge encore. Donc, je pense qu'on s'en est sorti, quoi.
On s'en est sorti ?
Maintenant, on va essayer d'avoir un emploi, d'avoir une vie normal.
Mais avec cette tête, c'est compliqué quoi.
Ça finit comme ça ?
Etle jeu recommence aussitôt !
P*tain. J'aimerai tellement que vous me disiez vos interprétations de cette fin.
Si on se transforme en caillou
ou si juste, l'enfant est libre,
ou si on est libre mais on est mort dans la foulée.
Je sais pas.
Je suis perdu.
Je suis perdu, en tout je suis émoustillé.
En tout cas, c'est la fin de ce Let's Play !
Merci de l'avoir suivi. C'était assez ouf, p*tain.
C'est vraiment
des jeux qui font hyper plaisir.
Des bons jeux indés comme ça, pas très longs.
Mais qui sont vraiment des MasterPieces
Franchement, cette ambiance. C'était incroyable.
Graphiquement, c'était incroyable aussi.
C'était très très malsain.
Très très malsain.
Très très gore.
Et je pense que c'est un peu ce que vous avez kiffé, c'est que
on est finalement terrifié,
on est horrifié quand on joue à ce jeu.
Mais, pas pour les mêmes raisons que quand on joue à Five Nights At Freddy's.
Là, c'est juste l'ambiance,
les intentions des gens,
les attitudes des gens,
les décors qui sont vraiment bizarres.
Je ne vais pas vous mentir, mais je vais tout de suite chercher des explications sur cette fin.
Je suis hyper intrigué.
Je suis hyper intrigué. Bah, si vous avez des interprétations, n'hésitez pas à les laisser en commentaires.
Je suis curieux de lire tout ça et de voir de ce que vous pensez.
Et puis, écoutez, je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
Merci d'avoir suivi le Let's Play et on en refera peut-être un avant la fin des vacances d'été.
Portez-vous bien. À très vite. Je suis tout ému.
Ciao tout le monde.
Peace !
SpiderTroll ma chaine :)